inutile de le chercher sur la scène de
la justice
cet après midi guillaume dujardin
n'était pas là à l'énoncé du jugement
il vient pourtant d'être condamné à
quatre ans de prison dont deux avec
sursis
il sera aussi inscrit au fichier des
délinquants sexuels
bon les dix étudiants qui avaient porté
plainte contre lui c'est un soulagement
qui clôt deux ans de combat
compte tenu de leurs préjudices qu'elles
vont devoir porter avis évidemment que y
at il une condamnation qui correspond à
ce qu'elles ont vécu
c'est une vaste question le metteur en
scène avait propulsé le festival des
caves au plan national à l'université
son enseignement était recherché mais au
prix de consentement extravagant du
jardin insisté sur le jeune eu un gourou
capable de chantage sexuel
cette notion de harcèlement et plus
spécifiquement de chantage sexuel était
une infraction tout à fait
inhabituellement poursuivi c'est là
aussi très satisfaisant de devoir est
effectivement qu'on est en capacité
d'évoluer pour pouvoir appréhender tous
les comportements sexistes avilissant
humiliant c'est surtout la
reconnaissance
l'instrumentalisation du théâtre pour
assouvir
des besoins
sexuelle
de mathieu germain guillaume dujardin a
dix jours pour faire appel
les étudiants sont repartis sans un mot
de soutien de l'université de franche
comté qui dans cette affaire ne s'était
pas constituée partie civile